dave awancha is better known as vegas
dave
vegas dave is a sports gambler turned
tout a tout is somebody who sells their
picks or opinions
on who will win tonight's game um he
specializes in baseball but he sells his
his
picks uh on basically every sport
and he does so via instagram
didn't know anything about vegas dave
and i you know
started like you know most most
reporters do your first step is you you
start looking this person up um so come
across this instagram page and it's
glossy photos of him sitting on a
ferrari
throwing cash in the air and and all
this stuff
it started with the most expensive
sports card in history and what i found
was a more interesting story which is a
very complicated
person who's had a complicated life
case dave became well known in the
sports gambling circuit in 2015
after collecting 2.5 million dollars on
a futures bet that the kansas city
royals would win
the world series that year and then the
following year in february he
won 2.3 million dollar payout when the
denver broncos defeated the carolina
panthers
for super bowl 50. so at that time
owancho was making bet he was placing
bets at
uh two different sports books in las
vegas under fraudulent social security
numbers so that year when he uh had the
winning ticket
uh for the for the denver broncos he
couldn't collect the money
uh because the federal government was
investigating him and
um told sportsbooks not to to pay him
out vegas dave
um took a plea deal and the plea deal
was was
pretty sweet he pled guilty to a
misdemeanor um you know being charged
with 19 felonies he was able to
plead down to one misdemeanor and
forfeit half a million dollars and he
was banned from las vegas sports books
for
three years where the story turned for
me
was when when i found out that dave sold
a counterfeit card
if you're new to sports cards one of the
holy grail
cards um nba cards that is is the
1986 fleer michael jordan rookie card
i found out that in 2017 he sold a
collector
who's a guy who lives in california this
card for
eighteen thousand dollars so i was able
to track down
um the buyer and i talked to him i
talked to the grading service that that
confirmed the card was fake he claims he
didn't know it was counterfeit
um but yeah to me that kind of put in
perspective
of vegas dave like he's a hustler
people think his pick selling business
is a lot of smoke and mirrors
and he he advertises these packages as
ways to make money you know my
conversations with dave i'd ask him what
his strategy is and
he says he just has an innate talent of
predicting who's gonna win so to me you
know as a reporter
that makes me skeptical because you
don't believe people who
say they can predict the future there's
not a human being who can
right so after talking to about a dozen
vegas dave customers i decided it was
time to
buy a package myself and to see what the
experience was like
elantra suggested to to bet on the
minnesota twins to win 35 units
so the twins lost um so that was the
first bet that went
south the next wager was a money line
bet on the cincinnati reds to beat the
chicago cubs for
20 units uh the reds lost and so that
was
800 down the drain you give him money
and he sends you an email with like hey
guys this is
the the teams you should bet on and
that's it it's a very simple business
so i found out every state he lived in
and started looking
at the courts see if i can find any
police or
arrest records and really that
opened my eyes um because everywhere
that dave has lived he's been in
had some kind either lawsuit or run in
with the law
he's been sued by ex-girlfriends he's
sued ex-girlfriends
he's filed for bankruptcy protection in
the early 2000s
and really the list goes on and on um uh
dui
a uh domestic violence charge that was
downgraded to a disorderly conduct and
then just this kind of whole picture
arose he it was very defensive on on
everything
um you know brought up the the
bankruptcy in the foreclosure and he's
like that's 20 years ago
then when it got to the counterfeit card
that i found that out later and
um after my last interview with him i
found that out so i emailed him multiple
times
our fact checker emailed him about it
and he did not
respond really the conclusion of
my reporting is that dave is not who he
says he is
he took a screenshot of the picture and
the headline
of my article which is you know it seems
like it's going to be a story about
the guy who sold the most expensive
baseball card in the world which which
it is but um it makes no mention
of the the less savory aspects of his
career
um and so he said you know thank you
forbes for the the feature story
and no link to the story uh so that has
been his
his way which is you know you got to
hand it to him it is a smart way to
handle bad press